[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Ryan Chester I'm the chess
club manager here for the st. Louis
chess club we are here with a new series
called don't get forked
in any of series we are going to have
contestants from the Chess Club members
and employees come up and they have to
figure out how to not get forked in a
certain position now clearly you have to
make the best move in the position but
they will all involve not getting forked
all of our puzzles are supplied by
international master Eric Rosen so thank
you very much for that in our first
contestant is Emily Trask longtime chess
club associate all right welcome to our
very first puzzle of don't get Forge and
like that is here to figure this puzzle
out it is blacks turn to move White has
a potential fork here and you have to
figure out how to not get forked you
have won the very best move to make is
what you need to do there might be
multiple moves but you want to make the
very best move
alrighty ready in three seconds you're
gonna turn around and you get 30 seconds
to move are you ready yeah 3 2 1 go
alright Emily is now looking at the
puzzle trying to figure out where to
move for black alright lots of pieces on
the board here lots of potential moves
but you want to find the best one to not
get report
all right you have about 15 seconds left
show us on the board all right is that
correct
[Music]
all right it looks like Emily Trask is
successfully solved the puzzle and has a
prize with two things one a
complimentary fork and two you get to
keep your job here at the Chess Club
thanks for joining us all right thank
you for joining us in our inaugural
potentially last episode of don't get
forked please like us share our videos
subscribe to our channel if you have a
good fork puzzles send them to info at
st. Louis chess club or you'll see that
down here thanks a lot